[Música]
le tiene miedo a los gatos negros
abriría un paraguas en un interior Qué
siente ante el número 13
crea o no en ellas quizás estas
supersticiones les resulten familiares
Pero cómo es que la gente en todo el
mundo Toca madera o evita pisar las
grietas en la acera Bueno aunque no
tienen bases científica muchas de estas
prácticas y creencias extrañas tienen
orígenes extraños y específicos debido a
que implican causas sobrenaturales no
sorprende que muchas supersticiones se
basen En la religión por ejemplo el
número 13 se asociaba a la bíblica
última cena en la que Jesucristo cenó
con sus 12 discípulos antes de ser
detenido y crucificado
la idea resultante de que tener 13
personas a la mesa era mala suerte se
expandió a que el 13 era un número de
mala suerte en general ahora este miedo
al número 13 llamado
triskaidecafobia es tan común que muchos
edificios en el mundo saltean el piso 13
y los números pasan del 12 al 14 Claro
que muchos consideran verdadera la
historia de la última cena pero otras
supersticiones vienen de tradiciones
religiosas en las que pocas personas
creen o incluso recuerdan tocar madera
se cree que viene del folklore de los
antiguos indoeuropeos O quizá de quienes
los precedieron que creían que los
árboles eran hogar de varios espíritus
tocar un árbol invocaba la protección o
la bendición del espíritu interior
y en cierto modo esta tradición perduró
mucho Después de que desapareciera la
creencia en esos espíritus muchas
supersticiones comunes hoy en países
desde Rusia hasta Irlanda se cree que
son vestigios de religiones paganas
reemplazadas por el cristianismo pero no
todas las supersticiones son religiosas
algunas tienen base en coincidencias y
asociaciones desafortunadas por ejemplo
muchos italianos temen al número 17
porque el número romano 17 reorganizado
forma la palabra bixi que significa mi
vida había terminado del mismo modo la
palabra para el número cuatro suena casi
idéntico a la palabra morir en cantonés
así como en idiomas como el japonés y el
coreano que han tomado prestados los
números chinos y como el número uno
también suena como la palabra debo el
número 14 suena como la frase debo morir
son muchos números a evitar en
ascensores y hoteles internacionales
y créase o no alguna supersticiones
realmente tienen sentido O al menos lo
tuvieron hasta que olvidaron su
propósito originario por ejemplo los
escenarios teatrales consistían en
grandes fondos pintados que los
tramoyistas subían y bajaban y silbaban
para hacerse señas entre sí los silbidos
de otras personas podían causar un
accidente pero el tabú contra el silbido
entre bastidores aún existe hoy mucho
Después de que los tramoyistas empezaran
a usar auriculares de radio
del mismo modo encender tres cigarrillos
con la misma cerilla podría traer mala
suerte si uno fuera un soldado en una
trinchera y encender una cerilla tanto
tiempo podría alertar a un francotirador
enemigo la mayoría de los fumadores ya
no tienen que preocuparse por los
francotiradores pero la Superstición
sigue viva porque la gente se aferra a
estos vestigios de religiones olvidadas
coincidencias y consejos anticuados no
son totalmente irracionales Sí pero para
muchas personas la supersticiones tienen
más de hábito cultural que de creencia
consciente después de todo nadie nace
Sabiendo evitar caminar bajo las
escaleras o silbar en interiores pero si
uno crece con su familia que le dice que
evite estas cosas lo más probable es que
se ponga incómodo incluso tras entender
lógicamente que no pasará nada malo
y debido a que hacer algo como tocar
madera no requiere mucho esfuerzo seguir
la Superstición a menudo es más fácil
que resistirse a ella además la
supersticiones a menudo parecen
funcionar quizá recuerde un buen jonrón
al usar sus calcetines de la suerte es
nuestro sesgo psicológico en acción es
mucho menos probable que recuerde todas
las veces que falló usando los mismos
calcetines pero creer que funcionan
podrían hacerle jugar mejor dándole la
ilusión de tener mayor control sobre los
acontecimientos
en situaciones donde esa confianza puede
marcar una diferencia como los deportes
esas locas supersticiones podrían no ser
tan locas después de todo
desea ver máster en español haga clic en
suscribirse nunca se sabe lo que podría
aprender a continuación
[Música]